[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
SCOTT HUGHES: All
right, so we are
ready to move to
the next lecture.
I'm going to record today.
So if we just quickly
recap the highlights
of what we did in
our previous lecture,
the goal of this lecture
was to take all the tools
that we have built and
develop a theory of gravity.
So the two ingredients
to this-- first
we're going to assert that we
take a valid law of physics,
something that is
well-understood in a local
Lorentz frames, which
we take corresponding
to a freely falling frame
when gravity is invoked,
and we will carry it
over into a general form
by rewriting that law
in a tensorial form.
The example I went
through was that if I
assert that an object
is unaccelerated, then
I can normally
write that by saying
that the proper derivative
of the velocity is zero--
or if you like the
second derivative,
positional on the
world line is zero--
that carries over to saying that
the parallel transport of the
of the four velocity,
along the four velocity,
is equal to zero.
If I require conservation,
local conservation of energy
and momentum to be asserted
in my local Lorentz
frame, my freely falling
frame in the form
that it has zero divergence
with a partial derivative,
that [? carries ?]
over in general
to zero derivative with
a covariant derivative.
Our second ingredient
is to try to understand
how it is that I can build my
theory of spacetime-- excuse
me.
How I can build my spacetime
given a distribution of energy,
matter, and momentum.
We are guided by the Newtonian
field equation, which tells me
the Laplace operator
on Newtonian
gravitational potential
is 4 pi G rho.
By studying the equation of
motion for Newtonian gravity
and comparing it to the geodesic
equation in the slow motion
limit for a spacetime
that deviates just
slightly from the flat space
on a special relativity,
we noted that this phi is
closely related to G00.
It's precisely equal
to up to a factor of 2.
It's a bit of an offset
from the negative 1
that you get in the
special relativity limit.
We noted that this is
not a healthy equation
from the standpoint
of being a ten--
of formulating things
in terms of tensors,
because rho is a particular
component of the stress energy
tensor.
Doesn't make any sense to
have a properly covariant eq--
if we want a properly
covariant equation,
it makes no sense to pick out
one component of a tensor.
So we upgraded rho to T mu nu.
And we looked for, noting
that two derivatives
of the potential is something
like two derivatives
of the metric, which must be
two derivatives of a curvature,
we said, OK, it's got
to be a curvature tensor
on the left-hand side, and
it's got to be a two index one,
and it's got to be one
that has no divergence
so that this equation respects
the local conservation
of energy and momentum.
And that led us
by requiring that,
in the appropriate
limit of slow motion--
well, in this case,
really it's just
sort of a weak deviation
from special relativity.
By requiring this
correspondence to hold,
that force, the proportionality
between my curvature tensor
and my stress energy
tensor will be
8 pi G. If you want to work in
units where the speed of light
is not set equal to unity,
it's 8 pi G over C to the 4th.
So that's fine.
This is, in fact, exactly
how Einstein originally
derived this.
And it's a very physical, very--
it's a very physicist
kind of an argument.
There is a another route
to the field equations,
though, which I would
like to talk about
in this next lecture.
And what's interesting is
that, historically, this route
was actually developed at
almost the exact same time
that Einstein developed this
way of coming up with the field
equations that are going to
describe relativistic gravity.
This particular
route helps us to--
I'd say it clarifies
some of the choices that
are made that lead to
this particular framework
for the field equations.
And as we'll see as we get
to the end of this lecture,
it helps to illustrate
how it might
be-- if general relativity is
incomplete in some way, how
we might systematically
add a little bit
of additional
framework, a little bit
of an additional structure.
It gives us, what is
the most natural way
to introduce additional
degrees of freedom,
additional ways of
modifying things?
So the framework I'm
going to talk about today
is something that allows us
to much more naturally move
beyond what this might
be, just in case--
Einstein, at some
point, we're going
to likely find that
general relativity is not
quite adequate.
It doesn't describe
everything to the degree
that we are able to
measure everything.
This will give us the
tools to go beyond that.
So the particular route
I'm going to [? derive ?]
is found by varying a
particular Lagrangian.
We're going to
essentially define
an action principle for the
gravitational interaction.
So I will call this
lecture the field equation
via the Einstein-Hilbert action.
That is the same Hilbert of
Hilbert Spaces, David Hilbert,
mathematician who was active
at about the same time
that Einstein was at his
peak research productivity.
As I said, this way of
thinking about things
and this formulation that
allows us to re-derive this,
it was developed
almost in parallel
to Einstein's formulation
of general relativity,
so much so that they
practically overlapped.
But it must be said that
Hilbert gives priority
to Einstein on this.
Hilbert gave
Einstein the priority
because he felt that Einstein
really clarified the physics.
And it was his insights that
led to this way of thinking
about gravity, even
though in some ways
he came up with a
way of understanding
where the field equations come
from that is somewhat more
elegant.
So let me first
sketch schematically
how we're going to do this.
Schematically, what we
do is we define an action
as the integral of a Lagrange
density over all of spacetime.
So we're going to
write our action as S,
and we're going to write it as
an integral over our spacetime
coordinates of some
Lagrange density.
So this is not a lot
in field theories.
This Lagrange
density is something
that depends on the
fields you are studying.
The action must itself
be a Lorentz scalar.
If I'm working in a
freely falling frame,
it cannot be something that
depends upon the particular
frame that one is using.
And so one often writes this.
You explicitly call
out the square root
of minus G. That is
necessary in order
to make your little
coordinate interval here
be a proper volume integral.
And just to make a little bit
of a notational difference,
let's call L hat the version
of the Lagrange density
that has that weighted
in there, like so.
So this will, in fact, be--
so this entire integral, both
of these entire integrals,
are Lorentz scalars.
This is a proper
element of volume,
and so this is a proper Lorentz
covariant well-defined Lagrange
density.
So whenever you have
an action principle,
you proceed via an
extremization procedure.
So suppose your Lagrangian--
I'm going to write this
very schematically.
Suppose it depends on
some set of fields.
When you extremize this, that
amounts to our requirement
that the action be
stationary with respect
to a variation of the fields.
So if I vary my fields, I'm
going to vary my action.
And let's just schematically
write this using
the first form of things here.
I will then say, however,
my Lagrangian varies,
as I vary whatever fields it
depends on, this must be zero.
That is my stationarity
requirement.
For this to occur, for this to
be valid for arbitrary field
variations, I will
then deduce from this
that the variation of the
Lagrange density itself
with those fields
must be equal to zero.
When I do this, this will
then lead to Euler Lagrange
equations for my fields.
Now, many students in the
class may have already
seen things like this.
But for those who have not, let
me work through a fairly simple
example.
So let's imagine that I have
a Lagrangian that just depends
on a scalar field phi and
derivatives of that scalar
field.
So L is going to
depend on some phi
and derivatives of that phi.
In my notes actually, imagine
there might be multiple scalar
fields.
Let's just keep it simple here.
We'll just have one scalar
field and its derivatives.
When we do our
variation, it's going
to be important that we treat
variations of the derivative
differently from
variations of the field.
At the moment, I'm going
to focus on flat spacetime.
We'll see what happens when the
spacetime's a little bit more
interesting in
just a few moments.
And what I'm going
to do is imagine
that phi varies like so, and its
derivative varies like so, OK?
So let's apply this.
I want to look at a variation
of this thing with respect
to my fields.
So when I do my variation
of the action S,
I get one term that will arise
in the variation in the field
phi, and I will get
another term that
arises due to the variation
in the derivative.
That term is potentially a
little bit problematic for us.
I'm going to gloss over
a couple of details.
But essentially what you
want to do is, at this point,
apply integration by parts.
When you apply
integration by parts,
you can move this derivative
onto this term here.
And in so doing, your delta S
becomes something like this.
Caution-- I'm being a
little bit glib here.
That is only true if--
when you do this properly,
there is kind of a boundary term
that I'm assuming
can be discarded.
I don't want to get lost
in the weeds associated
with that right here.
Our goal is just to sort of
sketch the main physical ideas.
But I will say that
this is something
that should be treated
with a little bit of care.
And I highlight
this because there's
going to be a similar step that
I'm going to sort of go over
with a little less care than I
would like as we move forward,
and I'll comment on
that at that time.
Having done this and
assuming that the discarding
of the boundary term
is safe for me here--
actually, let me just
make one further comment.
This is being done at
over all of spacetime.
And so when I do
that, I'm essentially
assuming that the boundary
is the boundary of infinity,
which doesn't really exist, OK?
So that's one reason why you
can generally get rid of it
in this case.
And it turns out
to be fairly safe.
I'm highlighting
this point because it
should be stated
a little bit more
carefully than I
have it in my notes.
And when we apply
this to gravity,
there's a little
bit of a subtlety
there that I will
comment on at that time.
For now, I'm just
going to say, great.
So that sort of works good.
That works out very
good, very well.
And in order for this
to be equal to zero,
the term inside my square
braces must vanish,
and so I wind up with Euler
Lagrange equations, which
my field, my field phi, must
satisfy given the Lagrangian L,
OK?
Now let's just take
it one step further.
So I haven't said yet where
the Lagrangian comes from, OK?
As I sort of indicated, when
I sketch this over here,
it's going to depend on the
nature of the field you study.
So it's very common when you're
studying, say, a scalar field
and flat spacetime
that you imagine
that your Lagrangian has what
we call a kinetic term, which
is proportional to
something that's quadratic--
whoops-- in the
derivatives of your field.
If it is massive, you
may have another term
which sort of looks almost like
a potential energy in which you
get something that looks like
the field squared coupling
to a parameter with
the dimensions of mass.
Take these derivatives,
so taking the derivative
of this Lagrangian with
respect to the field,
that's quite simple.
You just get m squared phi.
Take the derivative with respect
to the field's derivative,
what pops out of this is--
pardon me.
[INAUDIBLE] looks like this.
Now, take one more derivative
this guy, pardon me.
Just one second.
Yeah.
My apologies.
I was just looking
over my notes.
You just get the wave operator,
the flat spacetime wave
operator, acting
on the field phi.
And the Euler Lagrange
equations give us
the following wave
equation governing
this field in flat spacetime.
This is a result known as the
massive Klein Gordon equation.
So that's great.
How do we apply this to
our theory of gravity?
So there's two things
that we need to decide.
One is, what fields am I going
to build my Lagrangian out of?
And so I'm going to come back
to this point, because there
actually is a choice to
be made here, which is--
it's a little non-obvious.
And I'm going to
have a brief aside
where I discuss for a moment a
slightly different way of doing
it than what I'm
going to cover here.
But we're going to
vary the metric.
We're going to treat the metric
as our fundamental field.
And so when I write down
the Lagrangian for gravity,
I'm going to imagine that
it's a function of the metric,
and that would be the
thing that I vary.
The other issue is, what
should I use for my Lagrangian?
So the principle which I'm going
to use to make the choice here
applies to the gravity.
So my question is-- pardon me.
My writing and my brain are
getting out of sync here--
how do we choose our Lagrangian?
How do we choose L?
So it must be a scalar,
or a scalar density
if I want to take in bearing in
mind that factor of square root
G, must yield a scalar action.
And here's why I'm going
to make a real decision
with consequences.
It must be built from
curvature tensors.
The reason I choose to make it
something that is constructed
from curvature tensors is that
I want this Lagrange density
to be something that I
cannot get rid of by changing
my reference frame.
If it's the metric, I can make
the metric flat at any point
simply by going into a
freely falling frame.
It has something to do with
the Christoffel symbols,
or rather with my connection.
I can make that vanish by going
into a freely falling frame.
I cannot get rid
of the curvature.
So this point two here,
this second point,
this follows because this cannot
be something that is eliminated
by changing my
frame of reference.
I claim, based on that, that
the simplest action of all,
the one that you should
at least start with,
the one that is least ornate
and that encompasses these two
principles, is I'm going
to choose the L hat.
in other words, the one
I'm going to separate out,
the factor of
square root minus G.
I want this to be
the Ricci scalar.
It's the simplest possible
thing that I can make out
of curvature tensors
that is a curvature
and is going to
give me a scalar.
One could make
other choices, OK?
And in essence, that is the
reason I am doing this lecture,
is I want to highlight the
fact that this particularly
simple choice, we're going to
see it reproduces the Einstein
field equation.
And so, in that sense, general
relativity, we're going to see,
is really the simplest
geometric theory of gravitation.
One could make more
complicated ones, OK?
But this is the simplest one.
And in the last couple
minutes of this lecture,
we'll sort of explore how we
can make it a little bit more
ornate.
So let's begin with this.
So I'm going to write S
equals the integral of all
these things.
And let's be blunt.
Because I'm allowed to cheat
because I'm the professor,
I'm going to throw in a proof
factor of 1 over 16 pi G, OK?
Now, I am going to regard
my curvature tensor.
Like I said, I'm going to
regard this as something that
is built from the metric.
So this form in which
I've written here,
I'm just saying schematically
that Ricci itself
is built from the metric.
The Ricci scalar is the
trace of the Ricci curvature.
When I vary this thing,
what I would like
is to see what happens--
whoops, forgot my integral.
And I'm going to vary it
in the following way, OK?
let's just clean up my
indices a little bit here.
I like to keep
things consistent.
I'm going to confuse myself.
Let's leave them like that.
This is fine, OK?
So here's what I
want to evaluate.
I'm going to do a
variation of these things.
I'm going to assert
the variation in the--
well, I'm not going to assert.
What I'm going to do
is do this variation.
That will give me the
variation in the action.
For this to be
stationary, I'm going
to require that
this equals zero.
So what this tells me is I need
to work this variation of what
is in square braces out.
I need to work this
out right here.
All right, so this needs be done
with some care, so let's do it.
First, the thing
which I'm going to be
looking at variations
of, basically, I'm
looking at a variation of--
I want to know how this
changes when I vary the metric.
This is going to break
into three pieces.
I'm going to want the variation
of the square root of minus
determinant of the metric.
And then this will come
along for the ride.
I'm going to want to look at--
well, I'm going to
get one piece that's
just the variation
of the metric itself.
Don't need to do too
much more with that.
That actually already
has the factor
that I want to factor out there.
And then I'm going
to have a term that
looks like what I get when I
vary my Ricci curvature, OK?
So these are the three pieces
that I need to worry about,
really just two.
This one's kind of trivial.
This one's a little
more complicated.
All right, so when I vary my
square root of minus G term,
we discuss this a little
bit in a previous lecture
where I introduce some, what
I call, party tricks involving
the determinant of the metric.
You go back and
take a look at this,
you'll see that
this can be turned
into the following
calculation, OK?
When you vary your Ricci tensor,
by something of a miracle,
you will discover that
this can be written
as a term that looks like
the derivative, should
be the difference rather, of
two covariance derivatives
of variations in your
Christoffel symbols, OK?
Now, I like to work out
what those variations
in the Christoffel symbols are.
These are a little bit lengthy.
Just bear with me while
I write these out.
OK, as promised, it's
a little bit lengthy.
Using those two terms,
OK, using that term,
setting the indices
as appropriate
and taking those covariant
derivatives, what you will then
find when you evaluate
the important combination
to give me that term that
involves my Ricci variation
looks as follows.
So I'm going to
take those things,
put them together to make
my delta Ricci tensor,
and then trace over it.
And you get a lot of
cancellations when you do that,
such that the final result--
Notice no free
indices on this, OK?
So I've got derivatives
hooking onto the Gs here.
The mu nu is hooking
up to that mu nu there.
And before I manipulate
this further,
I'm just going to note that
this is in the form of--
you can write this as the
divergence of some vector
field.
So I'm going to say that this
is the divergence of VA, OK?
Excuse me.
V alpha.
V alpha is implicitly defined.
It's basically this beta
covariant derivative
of all this junk here, OK?
You might think,
well, wait a minute.
I'm taking derivatives
of the metric here.
Why doesn't my covariant
derivative metric just give me
zero?
We need to be little
bit careful about that
because we are varying
the metric, OK?
And when we're
varying the metric,
once we have finished our
variational principle,
we will settle down to a
metric where that is the case.
But in the middle
of the calculation,
you just happy a little
bit more careful than that.
All right, so now let's put
all these ingredients together.
And what you wind up with,
combining all of these pieces--
Oops, pardon me.
Pardon me.
Actually, let me move
to another board.
I've run out of room.
This is the length
the expression.
My apologies.
OK, so this becomes--
make sure I have
enough room to get
the whole thing on the line.
OK, so fair amount of
analysis goes into-- you
put all those pieces together.
You combine them all.
And our goal is
to reassemble what
I've got up there on the top
of this middle board here.
So what this tells me
is varying the action--
whoops-- leads me to an
equation of this form.
OK, let's stop and look
at this for a second.
So variation of
the action gives me
something it looks like the
Einstein tensor contracted
on my variation of my
metric, plus this divergence
of this goofy vector field.
If that divergence of the goofy
vector field were not there,
we would be home free.
Imagine we could ignore it.
I would want to set
delta S equal to zero,
and that would give me
G alpha beta equals 0.
Now, I haven't said
anything about a source,
so that, in fact,
gives me exactly what
I would need to develop my
Einstein field equations,
at least in the case where
there's no stress energy
tensor.
In a few moments, we're going to
put a stress energy tensor back
into this.
But that's sort of the first
step, that-- that first line,
if I did not have
that divergence
of V, that would give me
exactly what I needed there.
So how do I get rid of
that irritating divergence
of a vector field?
Well, in Carroll,
it's pointed out that,
because this is a
perfect divergence
and it is a proper
volume integral,
one can invoke the
divergence theorem.
If you invoke the
divergence theorem,
and then imagine
this integral is
being done over
all of spacetime,
and you basically
say, well, I imagine
there's no boundary the same
because this covers all of time
and all of space, you would then
presumably lose contributions
at the boundary.
And then only the G alpha beta
equals zero term would remain.
That's not a bad
physical argument.
It's somewhat glib, however, OK?
Carroll himself
actually noticed this.
So in Carroll's
textbook, he himself
says that this is
not the rigorous way
you get rid of this, OK?
So for those of you who are
more mathematically purist,
if you're feeling dissatisfied--
but it's good on you.
That is the way you
should feel about it.
I as a physicist am reasonably
comfortable with this,
but I would like to do this
a little bit more rigorously.
There are, in fact, two rigorous
approaches to fixing this up.
One of them is, in
fact, quite beautiful.
And it was my goal to overhaul
this lecture and present method
one that I'm about to
write down in this lecture
that I'm doing right
here, right now.
And among the various tragedies
associated with the COVID-19
evacuation of our
campus and everything
moving into this online format,
a very, very minor tragedy
on the scale of everything
that's going on,
is that I just do
not have the time
to assemble the
note to present what
I was hoping to present to you.
I hope by the end of the
course to have enough bandwidth
that I can maybe type
some up and add them
as supplemental
notes to the course.
But for now, they
are not available.
So let me just describe what
I was going to present to you.
Method one is you do what is
called the Palatini variation.
When you do a
Palatini variation--
whoops-- you write the
metric-- excuse me.
You write the action like so,
but you consider your Ricci
curvature to be a
function not of the metric
but a function of
the connection.
Then when you do your
variational principle,
you don't just vary with
respect to the metric.
You vary it with both the
metric and your connection
coefficients.
When you do this, if you do
the calculation correctly,
you, in fact, get both
the Einstein equation,
the Einstein-- so again,
we've not introduced a source.
I'm going to talk about
source in just a moment.
So the Einstein
equation with no source
emerges, and you find
that your connection
must be metric compatible.
In other words, the
connection is such
that you are required to
have covariant derivative
of the metric equal to zero.
It's actually a beautiful
little calculation
because we sort of argue that
this was going to be the case--
when we were talking
about how to define
a covariant derivative,
we noted that there
are many ways to define
a transport operation.
This ended up being
one that allowed us
to define parallel transport.
That became something
that the physics drove us
to selecting as a very natural
choice for our connection.
This variation
doesn't necessarily
know anything about
that, but it shows
that when you do your
variational principle, treating
metric and connection as
separate degrees of freedom,
that parallel transport-driven
choice of the connection which
gives us the Christoffel symbols
emerges as the outcome of that.
Now, this is not a terribly
difficult calculation to do,
but there's a lot of details
you have to get right.
And I've got about a fourth
of it written up at this point
and just haven't had a chance to
get all the details completely
straightened out.
I really hope to
have the bandwidth
to finish it by the end
of the term, in which case
I will add it as supplemental
notes to the course.
The other thing you can do--
so there's absolutely nothing
wrong with the approach
that we started doing in
which we vary the metric.
And we just assume
from the outset
that my connection
arises from the metric
so that, the way we do it,
the connection and the metric
are not separate
degrees of freedom,
but the connection
arises from the metric.
And that is fine.
But if we do that, then when
you get down to this point,
you just have to be a
little bit more careful.
You essentially take this
argument that Carroll makes
and you have to just do
it with a lot more care.
So what you need to do
is define the boundary
associated with the divergence
integral very carefully--
whoops.
Associated with
divergence integral.
In doing so, you have
to very carefully treat
the curvature on that boundary.
So we are working
in four dimensions.
So it's a three dimensional
boundary of our 4D spacetime.
You can sort of
think of the boundary
as being a particular
sort of slice
through four
dimensional space time.
You pick a particular
three dimensional slice,
redefine that as the boundary
region of this integral.
And that requires
us to introduce
some additional concepts.
In particular, once you
pick out a particular slice
of space time, some of
the curvature associated
with the metric on
that slice isn't
intrinsic to the
spacetime itself,
but it's imposed
on the space time
by the manner in which
you have made that slice.
Sort of in the same way
that if I have a cylinder,
the surface of a cylinder
is intrinsically flat.
If I put two geodesics on it
and I parallel transport them
around, they remain perfectly
parallel forever and forever
and forever.
But it sure as
hell looks curved.
But that is because I have
taken this flat surface
and I have folded it up.
I have embedded it in a higher
dimensional space in such a way
that there's extrinsic curvature
that's been imposed on it.
When you are carefully looking
at the boundary of a four
dimensional spacetime, you also
need to very carefully treat
the extrinsic curvature
associated with how you put
that boundary on top of things.
When you do this
correctly, you find
you need to be a little
bit more careful with how
you define the Lagrangian.
And when you, in fact, do
that, it actually turns out
you don't get that
divergence term at all.
You get sort of a counter term
that cancels this guy away.
So for students who are
interested in seeing this
explored and discussed
in a lot more rigor
than I am prepared
to do, this is
discussed in appendix E of
Robert Wald's textbook, General
Relativity.
I will simply comment
that Wald's textbook
is one of the most mathematical
textbooks on this topic.
He does everything with great
rigor and a lot of care.
And the appendices is where
he puts his particularly
high-level, grotty details.
So this really is
something that is
beyond the level of where
we do a one semester
course like 8.962.
So it's unfortunate it
sort of pops up here,
which is why a
textbook like Carroll
does this in a
somewhat glib way.
I am personally a fan of
doing this Palatini variation.
And so, as I've
emphasized, I'm going
to try to clean that up
and make that available.
So what all of this
ends up telling us--
so let's take the
optimistic point of view
here that we have either
accepted the somewhat
glib argument that we
can discard that term,
or we sat down and we slog
through appendix E of Wald,
or we wrote up the
Palatini variation.
Doing this variation in
that case then leads us
to G alpha beta equals zero.
This is the Einstein
equation when
there is no source, when the
stress energy tensor is zero.
This is often called the
vacuum Einstein equation.
More generally, we
should treat the action
that we are varying as the
Einstein-Hilbert action
plus an action
associated with matter.
So a more general
form would be to write
S as the integral d4x square
root minus G R over 16 pi
G plus the Lagrangian for--
I'm just going to
say m for matter.
Could be matter and fields.
If you do that, then when
you look at your variation
and enforce that the variation
of the action equals zero,
this leads you to an
equation of the form--
that's given by this.
And so up to a numerical
factor, which I'll write out
in just a second,
you can basically
see that this variation
of my matter Lagrangian
becomes the stress
energy tensor.
In particular, if
you just look at this
and say, oh, I am going to
define T alpha beta as minus 2
divided by square root
of minus G, like this,
then the Einstein-Hilbert
variation
gives me exactly the
same Einstein equation
as we had before.
I have a set of exercises
in the notes, which
I'm not going to go
through because they're
slightly tedious.
And I think I'm going to
actually end a little bit early
here.
But I want to just describe
one of the ways in which this
can be used.
So suppose I pick as
my matter Lagrangian
minus one fourth
f mu nu, f mu nu,
where f mu nu is the Faraday
tensor that describes
electric and magnetic fields.
So what I want to
do is show that,
by applying this variational
principle that I've
defined over there to this--
but this gives me exactly
the stress energy tensor
that one expects for
electromagnetic fields.
OK, so defining my
electromagnetic action,
pull out the overall
factor of minus one fourth,
I integrate over my
spacetime coordinates.
And then notice the
way this is set up.
So I have f mu nu upstairs,
f mu nu downstairs.
Let's write my f mu nu upstairs
as f alpha beta downstairs
but with enough
prefactors of the metric
to raise those indices.
So I do a variation on this.
And the way I'm going to do
it is I will vary the metric.
When I do this, I will
not vary the fields, OK?
If one does variations of
those things, you can do that,
and you can use that to do
things like define your field
equations.
But what I want to do is
just see how, by varying
how the metric couples
do these things,
the stress energy
tensor emerges.
So in my notes, I go
through this calculation
with some care.
And what emerges at the end is
something that looks like this.
And in fact, it's
not too hard to show.
Dig into something, a
textbook like Jackson,
what is in square braces
there is, in fact,
the standard stress
energy tensor associated
with the electromagnetic field.
So this technique, this
definition I've put in here,
it does work in all the
cases that we know about.
And so this
variational principal
root to the field equations--
so punchline is
selecting L equals
R yields the Einstein
field equations
upon variation of the metric.
So I'll take a
sip of water here.
And then the question I
want you to sort of think
of at this point is, so what?
I mean, it's nice that there
is a second way to do this.
But did we need it?
Is it really
important that we have
the second way of doing this?
Well, here I want to
come back to a comment I
made as I began this lecture,
which was that our guiding
principle for formulating
this Lagrangian
was that it has to be built
out of curvature tensors,
and it has to be a scalar.
I would argue that
the Ricci scalar
is the simplest such
construction that does that.
But it is not the only scalar
made from curvature tensors
that will do this.
Imagine you wanted
to modify gravity,
or you wanted to come
up with a framework that
was consistent with
general relativity.
And remember, L equals R
gives me general relativity,
gives me Einstein's
field equations.
It gives me Einstein's
theory of gravity.
Suppose I want to
modify it in a way
such that things look just
like Einstein's gravity
for most of the universe,
but perhaps small differences
kick in when the curvature
is small in some sense that
will need to be characterized.
Well, one way you could
imagine doing this
is by adding a correction.
Suppose we try L hat equals R
minus alpha over R. That sort
of suggests that
this is going to lead
to corrections to the
framework of gravity
when the curvature scale is less
than or of order square root
of alpha.
It's actually a work of a
couple pages of algebra.
I can take this
modified Lagrangian.
I can go through exactly
this variational principles
that we spent today doing.
And when I do so, I find a
new field equation coupling
spacetime to my sources.
So vary the metric,
enforce stationarity
of the action, what you get
is a field equation that
looks like this.
Notice, set that
coupling alpha to zero
and it says G alpha beta equals
8 pi newtons GT alpha beta.
But introduce this
little scale here,
suddenly you've got all
this other stuff emerging.
This is an idea that was
proposed and explored
in a paper, if you want to
read a bit more about this,
by Sean Carroll et al,
published in Physical Review
D. It's now almost coming
up on its second decade.
So the reason why Sean and his
collaborators developed this,
I mentioned in my
previous lecture
that there's observations that
have driven us to consider
whether there is, in fact,
a cosmological constant
contributing to the large scale
structure of our universe.
And like good
scientists, you're always
looking for alternate
hypotheses that
could be tested or falsified.
And so what Carroll
et al pointed out
was the universe's accelerated
expansion, so the behavior that
is driving us to consider the
possibility the cosmological
constant, it's coming on
very, very large scales
where the curvature
is quite small.
Laboratory and solar system and
many other astrophysical tests
of the foundations
of general relativity
aren't as strong there.
So why not try something a
little bit out of the box?
And they said, let's think
about a theory of gravity
in which there are potentially
important modifications when
the curvature is small.
This is what resulted.
And they showed, actually,
that by appropriately choosing
the parameter alpha,
actually, this
is a point that's worth making.
Notice this is
introducing a scale, OK?
The theory doesn't
tell us what alpha is.
From the standpoint of the
analysis that motivated it,
it was a phenomenological
knob that they sort of
tweaked to see whether they
could explain observations.
And indeed, they
did find that they
could get pretty good
explanation of the accelerating
expansion of the universe
with this modified
theory of gravity.
But all good theories
are testable.
They're falsifiable.
They give rise to
hypotheses that you
can compare against data.
It turns out, if you
tune alpha to make
the expansion of
the universe work,
you get the orbits of the
planets in our solar system
wrong.
So this ended up not
being a viable theory,
but it was a pretty cool
thing to explore, OK?
And I think it serves as
a really wonderful example
of how, in a theory of gravity,
one formulates a hypothesis
and then tests it.
And then giving Sean
and his colleagues
all their due,
cheerfully accepting
the falsification when it
turned out it didn't work.
You know, it's a very,
very nice piece of work.
And I think it just
is a really good idea
of the power of this
action-based method
for considering modifications
to your theory of gravity, OK?
And it really
highlights the fact
that just choosing
your Lagrange density
as the Ricci scalar, that's
the simplest possible thing it
can make.
And that is a sense in
which general relativity
is the simplest of all
possible relativistic theories
of gravity.
Let me just give you
another example of--
actually, two more examples.
I'm not going to go through
them in great detail,
but just sketching the
way people sometimes
imagine modifying gravity.
So suppose I choose as
my gravitational action
my normal Einstein-Hilbert
term plus a term
that goes as the Ricci
curvature squared.
This is something that you
might expect to become important
when the curvature is large.
OK, so when R is
greater than R of order,
1 over beta, the second term,
will become more important
than the first term.
Again, we've introduced a scale.
There is some
theoretical prejudice
among the community that thinks
about these kinds of models
that perhaps this
scale has something
to do with where quantum
gravity effects begin to kick in
and classical general
relativity must be modified.
And so you can
imagine, you might
think that this beta
is on the order of,
when you work in units where
G and C are equal to 1,
H bar to the minus 1.
Actions like this often
emerge when you are studying--
they often show up when
you are studying theories
in which general relativity is
itself an effective theory that
comes about from averaging over
small scale degrees of freedom.
One more example.
What if there were, in
addition to the tensor,
the metric tensor
which describes
the geometry of space time--
what if the manner in which
the metric tensor coupled
to its source varied depending
on some additional field that
filled all of spacetime?
So you can imagine that your
gravitational action took
the usual form,
but it was modified
by some kind of a scalar
field that might itself depend
upon spacetime curvature, OK?
And you can imagine
then supplementing this
with an action for
the scalar field,
which, up to an overall constant
at least, I will write--
theories of this sort are
called scalar tensor series.
And what they
essentially amount to is
you imagine that
there is some field
in addition to the
metric of spacetime
which is affecting gravity.
You can almost think
of them as essentially
saying that the effective
gravitational constant varies
depending upon the strength of
the gravitational interaction.
So perhaps down
near a black hole
the Newton constant is bigger
or smaller or something than way
out in empty space.
Theories of this kind arise--
I should say terms of
this kind and the action--
quite naturally in a lot of
work in theoretical attempts
to quantize gravity,
things like that.
And so people like to pay
attention to these things
and to see what kind of generic
predictions they can make.
These are known as
scalar tensor theories.
And if you're interested
in seeing more about them,
Sean Carroll's textbook has a
full section describing them.
A little bit out of date now.
One thing that's kind of
interesting as we sort of think
about how the subject has
evolved over the years
that I've been teaching
it is that when
you have both a tensor
component, in other words,
a spacetime metric coupling
to your stress energy
tensor and you have
a scalar field,
you change the
dynamics of the theory.
And that ends up doing
things like changing
the character of
gravitational radiation
that is emitted from a system.
And so, very recently,
the most stringent limits
on these possible modifications
to general relativity
have come about from things
like LIGO observations
which have looked at
coalescences of black holes
and neutron stars.
And all of their
measurements are
consistent with
there being no scalar
modification to these things.
And so it helps to
set limits on many
of these theoretical frameworks
that introduce and look
at modifications to
GR which are motivated
by certain considerations.
This concludes the
first half of 8.962.
So if I'm just going to do a
quick recap of where we are
and where we are going, where
I want you to sort of sit
with things right now is that
you have this arsenal which
basically tells you that,
given the metric of spacetime,
you can compute the
motion of bodies--
this is done using
by geodesics--
you can characterize
the curvature
of that spacetime which
tells you about tidal fields,
and you now, as of
these last two lectures,
know how to get this by solving
the Einstein field equation.
What we will do in
the remaining lectures
that I'll be recording
and distributing
through this course's website
is solving this equation
and exploring the properties
of these solutions.
And so let me just sort
of say this equation,
if you go back to
think about what
goes into this-- at the
beginning of my next lecture
which I'll be
recording tomorrow,
we'll go through
this in some care.
But if you just think of this
as a partial differential
equation for the metric,
it is a god-awful mess, OK?
There's no nice way to put it.
I mean, it's just
a horrible mess
of coupled, non-linear,
partial differential equations.
We are going to look at
three ways of solving this.
Method one, we will think about
a kind of weak field expansion.
I'm going to imagine that
the spacetime corresponding
to the sources we are studying
looks like flat spacetime
plus a small correction.
That will allow me to take
this horrible coupled,
non-linear mess
and linearize, OK?
We will lay out the principles
for doing that methodically
in the beginning of
the next lecture.
Method two, we'll
see what happens
when we assert a symmetry.
One of the reasons why those
equations are such a mess
is that, in general,
there's just
a tremendous number
of terms that
are coupling to one another, all
sorts of things tying together,
and it's just very,
very complicated.
But if we imagine that
everything is, say, spherical
symmetric, then
that dramatically
reduces the number
of degrees of freedom
that the spacetime could have
even as a matter of principle.
And so we will actually
start by beginning
to explore the most
symmetric space times of all.
And I will lay out
exactly what that means.
And that actually turns out,
at least to within our ability
to observationally probe this--
that appears to describe our
universe on the largest scales.
And so when we do the largest,
the most symmetric things
possible, that
gives us spacetimes
that worked very well
for describing cosmology.
Making things a little bit less
symmetric but still highly,
highly symmetric, that allows
us to describe very strong field
objects, things which
I'm going to call--
I'm going to just
call them stars.
What I really mean
by that are these
are objects that are just
self gravitating circle fluid
balls, OK?
And we will see how they can
sort of hold themselves up
against their own gravity, what
their spacetime looks like.
There's all sorts of
interesting properties
that emerge from them.
And eventually we
actually find that you
reach a set of configurations
where there is no--
no fluid can be allowed by the--
let me try that sentence again.
You can find configurations
such that no fluid allowable
by the laws of physics can
give you a stable object.
They produce black holes.
That will basically
take us, essentially,
to the end of the course, OK?
These two things have
a tremendous amount
of content in them.
And this is where a huge
amount of the literature
on general relativity
has focused its attention
over the past several decades.
In my last lecture or so,
I'm going to briefly describe
general solutions.
What do you do if
there is no symmetry,
there is no weak expansion,
no weak parameter
you can expand in?
You just have to deal with
the non-linear, bloody mess
that these equations are
and then try to solve it.
And what this will do is allow
me to explore and tell you
a little bit about the field
of numerical relativity, which
is what you do
when you just want
to solve these things with no
approximations, no assumptions
that simplify it whatsoever.
Just take Einstein's
field equations,
put it into a
computer, write a code,
hit Go, and see what happens.
So under the normal
schedule of things,
where we would
end today would've
been right before spring break.
And these lectures would start
up right after spring break.
Under the system that
we are operating now,
I do suggest you sort of
save this for a little while.
Make sure that you
understand what is going on
with these field equations.
And we will be ready to
explore the solutions,
and not just compute
these solutions
but also explore
things like motion
in them and their properties.
And we'll begin that process
immediately afterwards.
All right, and I will
conclude this lecture here.